we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p i do want to let
people know i came back from my week off
to 1100 unlistened to voicemails 1100.
it's going to take some time to go
through them all
i did get a couple of voicemails about a
particularly deranged anti-vaccine
bit of propaganda
i'm going to play one of those
voicemails for you this one is from troy
york who really has fallen for the
anti-vac stuff take a listen see if you
can even understand it and then i'll
explain it and tell you what's going on
uh mr pakman i would like for you
to that nfl player dj
thomas
at the age of 33
has died
and most likely this has to do with him
being forced
to take the vaccination
and
the number of people being killed
and dying after taking the vaccine
is untold because the media doesn't tell
us they are paid back to tennis
but it must be in the hundreds of
thousands
and the american people are not stupid
they know that these vaccines are an
attempt to kill much of the population
as much as possible
a large chunk of the at least and so
that that's you you probably get the
point that's probably going to be enough
so the nfl player demarius thomas did
pass away and that's very tragic
it had nothing to do with the covet
vaccine as far as there is any evidence
whatsoever to be uh presented
um
and the way that this spreads
is
unclear
but he had been having seizures for
quite a period of time
uh his cousin believes that he died from
a seizure or complication related to it
and there's no
reason at all to think that it had to do
with a vaccine i don't even know if he
was vaccinated but let's let's presume
he was
uh as i think most nfl players are at
this point in time
the way that this spreads
is that initially it's the opportunism
of
young person who should be the picture
of health because he's a football player
has died
and he was found dead it wasn't
a murder
it wasn't a car accident it was well he
had been having seizures and he was
found dead and we're still figuring out
the cause of death so it's an
opportunity to say
young guy dies no explanation must be
the vaccine that that's number one
then
in the news articles it is accurately
said
as of right now the exact cause of death
is unclear so you you've got the
opportunity and then you have
for what for a conspiracy theorist
the absence of evidence which starts to
be used as evidence remember that's a
key to conspiracism and conspiratorial
thinking if there's evidence for
something you say look here's evidence
if there's absence of evidence you say
that absence is an opportunity to assert
my belief about an explanation in this
case
we don't yet have the official cause of
death
and so it's a vacuum into which the
conspiracy can be inserted
and then of course
when all you have is a hammer everything
looks like a nail
and if you want to just attack vaccines
any death in which there is an
unexplained immediate cause of death you
say well it must have been the vaccine
so that's like the cycle that's the
cycle as it is
um and of course there is no evidence
whatsoever for it which is the most
important thing to keep in mind but
unfortunately a lot of people i i hadn't
even heard about
the fact that it was being asserted
that the vaccine was involved here i
googled it there's a ton of wacky people
making the assertion absent any evidence
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today i'm going to tell you what i was
up to during my break last week a lot of
really interesting things to tell people
about make sure you are a member so that
you get the bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com i will again restate my
offer to you that if you sign up for a
new listen to the keywords here a new
full price
yearly membership for sixty dollars
if you sign up and pay a dollar eighty
for your first month you don't qualify
okay this is new full price yearly
we will send you a free t-shirt of your
choice just email info
davidpakman.com after signing up tell me
the t-shirt style
color
and size you want as well as your
mailing address we'll get those right
out to you we also are doing a january
1st midterm kickoff membership special
if you've been thinking about signing up
and waiting for just the perfect time
everything has to align for you to sign
up
this january 1st is a great day to do it
we'll be doing a huge membership special
we'll be notifying everybody on our
newsletter by email on the morning of
january 1st so just get on my newsletter
a mailing list at davidpakman.com and
then as a final reminder tomorrow we
will be doing the rescheduled final town
hall of the year it'll be streaming live
on the pacman live youtube channel 6 p.m
eastern 3 p.m pacific tomorrow december
28th hope to see all of you there but
for today we will talk to you on the
bonus show and you can sign up at
joinpackman.com to get instant access